الآن في الأخبار الصحية، يقول العلماء إنهم
يتوقعون أن يصبح المتغير الفرعي لفيروس كورونا jn1 هو
المتغير الرائد لفيروس كورونا حول العالم في غضون
أسابيع. وقد شهدت العديد من الدول في أوروبا
بما في ذلك الدنمارك وإسبانيا وبلجيكا
وفرنسا وهولندا أيضًا
نموًا هائلاً في jn1 ومعه
ارتفاع
حالات الاستشفاء لمزيد من الحالات، دعنا نحضر
مراسلتنا الطبية ميج
تيريل لشبكة CNN، ها نحن نعود مرة أخرى، قرأت هذا
الصباح أن هذا المتغير يمثل الآن 20٪ من
الحالات في الولايات المتحدة،
ما مدى سوء هذا الأمر، وما مدى قلقنا إذا كنا على ما يرام،
فهذا يرتفع بسرعة كبيرة
هنا  في الولايات المتحدة، إذا نظرت إلى
تقديرات مركز السيطرة على الأمراض لأه
النسب المتغيرة خلال الأسابيع القليلة الماضية،
يمكنك أن ترى أن هذا jn1
كان يرتفع بالفعل بسرعة كبيرة من
حوالي 4% فقط قبل بضعة أسابيع أه يرتفع
هناك الآن إلى أكثر  أكثر من 20٪ على المستوى الوطني
وهنا في الشمال الشرقي أكثر من
ثلث الحالات الجديدة ومن المتوقع
أن يصبح هذا هو السائد هنا في الولايات المتحدة
وفي جميع أنحاء العالم في غضون أسابيع قليلة
والآن عندما نفكر في المتغيرات
بالطبع حتى تصبح
المهيمنة يجب أن تكون أكثر لياقة من
المتغيرات التي جاءت قبلها، وعليها
إظهار نوع من الميزة ومع
هذا، يكون هذا سليل
متغير يعرف باسم ba.  2.86 وهو جزء
من مجموعة المتغير الفرعي Omicron الآن
كان الناس قلقين بشأن
المجموعة السابقة لأنها تحتوي على الكثير من الطفرات في
البروتين الشوكي الذي اعتقدوا أنه
سيكون قادرًا حقًا على التهرب من مناعتنا الحالية
بعد أن لا يبدو أن أحدها
ينطلق حقًا  ربما لأنه لم يكن
جيدًا في نقل العدوى إلينا، ولكن هذا
التغيير به تغيير إضافي ويبدو أن
الأخبار الجيدة أكثر ملاءمة على الرغم من أن
الاختبارات المبكرة تشير إلى أن اللقاحات يجب أن تظل
توفر حماية جيدة ضد
jn1، لذلك يوصي مسؤولو الصحة العامة
إذا لم تكن قد خرجت بالفعل
واحصلت على جرعة معززة محدثة من فيروس كورونا،
فبالطبع يأتي هذا في مواجهة
زيادة حالات العلاج في المستشفيات، ليس فقط في
جميع أنحاء العالم ولكن هنا في
الولايات المتحدة أيضًا من Co.